hey guys Ryan right over here hey guys
Jerry over here today us gangstas is
gonna watch the trailer for Straight
Outta Compton it's this story about NWA
and the I can't think of any other n
words there's like one end where they
comes to mind that I cannot say well
that's what NWA stands for is I know but
I still can't say I allowed to set it to
pay worth having because that's like a
proper name
you know like NWA stands for [ __ ] with
attitude so you just said it well yeah
but I'm not not trying to be a dick
about like it's in the title like you
have to read a title well Jerry you got
more balls than me he has six six balls
horrible deformity I'm trying to catch
an octopus now better bad it's crazy
takes pants with the tanks like I'm a
woman in a baby with the nearest heart
yeah you know if I can't do a beauty
really badly do play okay we're gonna be
so roofies clips and let's see chase
change the situation would you take you
just hit that first being hard how you
closing down the street all right my
sister and I was dunking
ah to Compton very own ice cube pz e and
dr. Dre I gotta tell you you're
witnessing history different stares
attacks you have a unique voice the
world meeting whoa w-what that's killing
me
this is only the tip of the iceberg
gentlemen what's going on what do you
have in that bag
are you kidding me you keep take that
song why my dandruff our art is a
reflection about reality as opposed to
be somewhere these are artists rap is
not an art you can come down here and
harass my clients because of what they
look like
look yonder listen be honest I don't
know anything about hip-hop but I know
that you're special
wouldn't be involved with this gangster
life
the people who's there
this is in the crimson blood this is a
car from the federal government I got
something ascetic Ebola man we can take
over the goddamn
Oh looks heavy man that looks really
heavy
everybody looks heavy yeah it looks like
it will have some cliches but everybody
picked us do your eyes and dark fall
that occurs and then yeah things didn't
work out in the end this is I mean grant
via there are all kinds of biopics about
people from all different backgrounds
but this seems like it starts in a
different place than a lot of the ones
we see it's cool that you know cuz Dre
Ice Cube ur still alive and Ice Cube is
still like very much in the public eye
yeah you know with all the movies he
does and stuff so we're good alright
boom it's cool to see that there's like
a biopic about these guys who are you
know cuz Dre produces a ton
yeah and to see that they're getting
their own movie is really cool we don't
have to wait till like they've passed
like and I heard they're like heavily
involved in the actual filmmaking of us
cool yeah which I'm sure will provide
much more authenticity like it's violent
it's like it's a it's a green band
trailer but it looks like it's gonna be
pretty violent
yeah no I'm saying it's like I don't
know but it looks like it'll be pretty
indicative of that time in place you
know just off a trailer it looks like
this could be an important film for the
rapper world we've had a few movies that
are based on rap eight-mile hustle and
flow but this is very different this is
about being a rapper to the to the big
public eye well yeah then and and this
is a group that was kind of you know
pioneers in a way like they brought rap
forward in a lot of ways you know yeah
yeah like NW is an important group in
hip-hop history because it's about their
cultural impact that they make people
get up in arms about things a little bit
now but like this is a time when people
were like really concerned about hip hop
and hip hop culture and I don't know the
exact you know years and whatnot in
exact events that happen but it was a
very tense time they had powerful music
and it was on the radio you know now
when we get rap music on the radio it's
rare we get something with powerful
lyrics oh yeah because it's like before
then you had it seemed like a lot of the
earlier rap was all like you know really
flippy beats you do dude yeah I was
walking down the street ever doing some
stuff like you had that like party rap
that was all kind of
and this was like really real and really
gritty and I said it was like this is
what our life I think his exact wine is
that I heard that line and I was like I
gotta memorize that our art is a
reflection of our reality yeah just that
one line alone sells me on this whole
together cuz I'm like if that is the
theme of this I would gladly watch this
film yeah totally cuz that's very
inspiring to check it out it's cool to
see a story about people a true story
about people who fought to be themselves
and succeeded and succeed greatly yeah
I'll be there yet - we don't yet anyway
guys thank you very much for mentioning
that was out it looks really rad if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and jerry
has a playlist on this channel too
check it out follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter and if you like my
reaction you can subscribe 1 million
subscribers Raul Torres I take it he's
some kind of Russian hey Ryan just
wanted to say you were one funny
[ __ ] I have [ __ ] a few mothers
in my days and keep up the awesome work
a shout out will make my [ __ ] day
well Raul Torres time to make your
[ __ ] day play aggressive you know
[ __ ] is an interesting word you know
it can mean so many things you could be
like you [ __ ] idiot or do you want to
start [ __ ] or today right [ __ ] a
that's [ __ ] awesome it could just
have if you just a plan buck is a
powerful word yes and no I mean because
it gets so much use now it's arguable
yeah somebody's hand that's immediate
end you could usually casually like Raul
could be like I don't know the [ __ ] that
was about yeah or he could be like [ __ ]
you Ryan
and I'd be like whoa [ __ ] you
there's your [ __ ] chatter